The canon is scored based on the number 10. So out of 10 is your 1. As you can see it's
split up into two parts. We have our accuracy and our presentation of the site. So we'll start
off with the accuracy first. So your accuracy is actually scored from a 4. So from the number 4
you're actually marked during your presentation of your pattern and then with that one any mistakes
that you make whether if it's a minor mistake you get a minus of a 0.1. If it's a major mistake
you get minus 0.3.
So I'll just let you guys know about the difference between the two. So with a minor mistake it's a
very very small thing. So say we're doing a out of block. If it's not your shoulder height maybe
it's a little bit lower or maybe it's a tiny bit higher. That's a minor mistake so that's a 0.1.
A major mistake would be you're supposed to do an out of block in the pattern but you forget and
say you do a reach hand strike instead. So that would be a major mistake.
So with a minor mistake let's say pattern 1 for example there's about 20 steps. It's not uncommon
to have up to maybe 14-15 mistakes in the 20 patterns. Sorry in the 20 steps. So the reason
for that one being it needs to be absolutely perfect to get to not get a deduction of 0.1.
So it's not uncommon to let's say there's 20 steps and you may let's say
15 mistakes. So what would that be? So we'll leave that there on this side and we'll come back
and we'll just calculate the score at the ending end. So a major mistake say you're supposed to
turn to the left but you turn to the right. That would be a major mistake. So obviously we do want
to try to avoid any of these major mistakes. So after we've done our pattern that's when we move
on to the presentation side. So the presentation as you can see it's from a score of 6. This
6 is actually split up into three parts. So we have 1, 2, 3 here. So with this one for a score of
2 is your power and speed. Your rhythm is also a score of 2 and your expression of energy is also
scored out of 2 as well. So we'll start off with the power and speed. So with this one whether it's
your blocks, your kicks, your strikes, your punches, anything you are that you do you need to be nice
so that it's one thing to have a very strong punch or a very fast punch but it has to be both
strong and fast to get high in that in that category. The next part is your rhythm. So the
rhythm when you do start your pattern there is a rhythm to the pattern. It's not just really fast
all the way through. It's not slow all the way through. There's a slow fast slow fast kind of
aspect to it as well. So you do need to kind of work on your rhythm and that's also scored out of 2.
The last bit is your expression of energy. So what is expression of energy? That's basically how
loud you shout. So how much intensity you have during your pattern as well. So say you're doing
your pattern really well. It's really fast and it's strong. Your rhythm is really great but you're
not shouting very loud or you can kind of tell the judges can kind of tell you're not really confident.
You're a little bit nervous so that's why we need to kind of improve on as well. So I just
come on up to this side. So with this one for color belts and black belts it's actually scored a
little bit differently. So if you're a color belt you'll actually your average so where the
judges actually mark you from it's actually from a 1.1. So this is your average. So say you did
alright. You did average compared to everyone else. Your score for 1, 2 and 3 it'll start from a 1.1.
If you're less than average in the judges eyes you might go down to say for your power and speed you
might get a 1 or even a 0.9. If you did really great you might even get a 1.3 or a 1.4. So each
individual category you need to obviously get as high as you can. If you're a black belt generally
depending on the competition you will be scored from a 1.3. So 1.3 would be your average that you
start from. So say your parents
speed was above average. You might get scored a 1.4 for now. Say your rhythm was only about average.
It wasn't amazing. It might be just a 1.3. But let's say you didn't shout very loud. So your
expression of energy your average was 1.3. It might drop to say let's say 1.0. So with this one we'll
come over.
Down to this side. So with this one as I was saying it's a total of 10. So let's see. So for
presentation we have 1.7, 1, 2, 3. So you added 3.7. Let's say you made 15 mistakes. So with this
one obviously don't be too discouraged if you do get pretty high in your mistakes. This is with the
three judges usually at the panel and each judge obviously it's very subjective. So from their point
of view you might have made a lot of mistakes or you may have made not a lot of mistakes as well.
So that's why we have the three judges and we average it out as well. Okay so say we did our 15
mistakes. Very small mistakes. So if they're all minus 0.1 it would be 1.5. So you go 4.0 minus 1.5
which equals 2.5. So this would be your accuracy score. So with our presentation like before we're
saying we got a 3.7. So we add these numbers after the judges are finished scoring. So you would get for this
pattern.
6.2 which is actually very good. So I'll just talk about a little bit more now about this number here.
So if you're a color belt, if you're a yellow or above and you do your patterns, it's not uncommon generally for a
color belt. The average is about a 4 to 5. So if you get a number between 4 and 5 out of 10 for your pattern, that's
actually generally considered pretty good. So anything above that you could consider yourself pretty good.
If you're a black belt, the average would say because we're talking here about the higher presentation as an average.
Anything from 5 to 6 is actually considered pretty good. And anything over a 7 is actually considered almost world-class.
for any of your patterns you generally need to pat yourself on the back you did an amazing job
so we just went through our poomsae scoring so just remember accuracy is a 4.0 presentation is
a 6.0 accuracy is judge during your pattern presentation is after and then we get two scores
that we add up and we get that number so with this one obviously uh say i was uh i was judge
number one i would give you a 6.2 there was another judge on the other side maybe he saw
a couple more mistakes than i did and maybe this one would be a little bit lower it might be a five
point something another judge on the other side they scored a little bit higher so we'd get the
three numbers and then we'd average that as well so i hope this helps you guys so make sure you
enjoy your poomsae competitions and anytime i make sure obviously you record down your numbers
as well so i hope this helps you guys so make sure you enjoy your poomsae competitions and
we cannot pause this time so minor errors major errors you can while you're watching your own
video okay and then after your performance you can rate your power and speed coordination of
rhythm and expression of energy okay okay so we cannot pause this night do it real time
okay so we cannot pause this night do it real time
Thanks for watching!